hey guys today is another style video
and it's all about shoes
they're very important right
[Music]
super important because you wear them
every single day of your life and so in
this video i want to share with you the
six basic types of shoes that every guy
must have let's get to it
[Music]
all right now just remember that this is
my personal opinion there are some guys
who only want two to four pairs of shoes
and that's fine because there are more
important things in this world than just
shoes or any other material things but
that's another video for another time
for me personally i like to be prepared
i like to have shoes for every occasion
or situation so let's get to the list
boots now i only got two different types
of boots chelsea boots you can't go
wrong with these they look smart stylish
and will fit in with most outfits for
casual and semi-formal events from all
the shoes i have these ones feel the
best to walk in that's because of their
design they even help you to look better
when you walk in them i got mine from
ace marks
and even though i have them for a few
years now they still look brand new
and then i got these rugged outdoor
boots from aldu in brown
and then these black ones from tosoni
now of course you might recognize them
from the banner on my youtube channel
man i love these rugged manly boots a
lot and you can wear them outdoor and
indoors
now just remember i'll add all the shoe
links for in the video description down
below if you want to check them out
[Music]
formal shoes
every man needs them you can't go to a
formal event without formal shoes and
you will need brown and black to fit in
with most outfits my favorites are the
monk straps or double monk straps
[Music]
they always look stylish and nothing
beats them
[Music]
now just remember if you want to wear
black shoes your belt needs to be black
as well
and if you wear brown shoes your belt
needs to be brown as well
sports shoes
you can't do sport without sport shoes
or you can try to because a lot of
people say well i can do what i want
well a lot of companies or sports
organizations
won't let you compete in a sport if you
don't have shoes now of course it
depends on what you do the sport type
like golf
or tennis
or football
weight and jogging
they all have their own unique shoes me
personally when i'm at home when i'm
working out when i'm jogging not as much
as i used to anymore because of my bad
knee but i like normal well we called in
my language in afrikaans takis
training and jogging shoes what makes
them even cooler is that you can use
them with normal casual outfits these
days and even some smart outfits
[Music]
i got these pumas because the shape is
perfect for my unique feet with a high
bridge and then i also got these nikes
[Applause]
sneakers
most guys out there love sneakers
including myself you probably already
have a pair there or two at home they're
comfortable they're quick easy to put on
and they also go with most of the
outfits casual
or smart
some guys they like different colors
like red blue yellow
i don't i just like black or white
because then it will fit in with most of
the outfits in my closet i got these
nice white ones from oliver cabell
[Music]
and these black ones from them as well
they look awesome and the quality is
really good as well
now if it's time for you to get some new
sneakers i'll add their links for you in
the video description down below because
they are good quality and they will last
you a long time
[Music]
outdoor and hiking shoes
now most of you you know that i love the
outdoors
i love being out in nature hiking
camping
and fishing
now personally for me i don't like shoes
that are too heavy when i'm outdoors i
like shoes that are light and
comfortable so my go-to shoes are these
guys from columbia tech light
[Music]
but if you prefer stronger shoes you can
check out the target shoes the
waterproof shoes from keen
[Music]
sandals
[Music]
every guy needs a pair of sandals
especially in summer
going to the beach or just chilling at
home
they are just so comfortable and easy to
wear
my favorite sandals are the ones from
cole haan zero ground but recently my
wife also got me these vuchi sandals
online from college spring
now these are the shoes that every guy
must own to be ready for each and every
occasion
[Music]
of course there are some others like
safety worker shoes
but not every guy will need it because
of their lifestyle then there are also
loafers or slip-ons
but not every guy will need it
especially if you already have formal
shoes boots and sneakers
so let me know in the comment section
down below what your favorite type of
shoes are that's taking you places in
the world and if you're new to my
channel remember to subscribe and
watch one of these videos here you might
like it and then always remember life is
short so don't waste
yours cheers guys